your brother
is your business partner yeah he is so
it's family it's a business it's your
business partner yeah i said at the
beginning he's bigger and stronger than
you i don't know i'm not trying to cause
a fight well you guys should definitely
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so
yes
is it fair to say you do pretty well
with the ladies
yeah okay
spoken like a true ladies man don't
reveal don't reveal your hand
um but your brother's your business
partner yes now if you met a girl met a
baddie fine ass girl she's in your life
now yeah how does that how do you manage
that with a serious relationship with
your brother with your business partner
can it get weird can it get
does your brother have a girlfriend like
how does that all work honestly i don't
think it can get i don't think it would
get weird because
uh like the initial topic successful man
i believe a successful man has balance
in his life he has balance he's able to
control business work relationship work
family work and different that he's able
to balance everything so it would it
wouldn't it wouldn't be an issue it
wouldn't be an issue at all
everything that i handle business work
with my brother and i that's my brother
and i
anything within the relationship that's
with whatever woman i'm with god so what
do you guys think is a more
dangerous
relationship
mixing hold on mixing
business with your white like wife or
business with a family member what has
the more
uh like is your brother this is your
boyfriend this is your wife what has
what can get uglier
i think the business i would say your
wife
and i'd say him oh really because
who's older who's older
i'm older so because you know his
younger brother
remembers
what they did when wrestling when they
were five years old yeah right okay and
so for example i got i'm filipino right
big family not one family members in
business with me yeah because we take
things so sensitive with each other so
but my wife she met me at a different
time of my life she met with
kids divorce
lives beating me up but i get my head on
the street hopefully and she can invest
in a guy like me
and so it's it's a lot easier that way
family not so much god right but you
disagree i disagree i would say wife
because
a relationship in business they're
they're too they're too they're too
different they're in my opinion they're
a bit they're a bit different and the
way you
talk to your wife you wouldn't talk to
you know a business partner in that
sense of the way and the thing is
like i was i said before
you as a man you're you're innately
you're gonna just you're gonna lead so
whatever you do whatever you whatever
you do whatever you are your wife sees
it that's a leader that is a leader so
when she decides to all right cool i'm
going to be that business
i need to tell him something because
this is my business partner and you're
like whoa whoa whoa hold on yeah you're
my wife yeah that's right you're my wife
and that's that's an issue because now
at that point she's looking at you like
well
well
you know
i'm wife i'm business i'm talking
business and when i talk business you
you get like
this so i would i would say it's more
it's more shaky it's more rocky but so
my con argument is this at least a
husband and wife they're intertwined
right brothers they're not intertwined
he gets married he gets married who
knows what's going to happen in his
business now
because now he's got to listen to his
wife he's got to listen to his wife kids
so there might be at the track because
they're not intertwined
so
you want to weigh in on this
can you ask the question one more time
i said what is more of a more of a
dangerous situation going into business
with family or going into business with
your significant other
uh definitely i think with the
significant other because
i guess family bad or good it's your
family right yeah of course you cannot
talk to them but i do think that it's
easier to get into business with
significant other than with family
because family
unfortunately doesn't know you as well
as um at least in my family you know
doesn't know you as well as your
significant other does because again
everybody's spread everybody's working
nobody's actually
caring in a sense of what is it that you
like
so i think it's harder
to go separate ways with
wife and it's easier to actually work
together with significant others yeah go
very good point i want to tell her
because she's in business with her
family
or her family's in the business
she's in paris with her parents because
i'm about to have my daughters in
business with me now because one of them
just really got promoted yeah i know it
still stopped stopping so milani just
got licensed and she just got promoted
directors so so
the hardest thing for me i can't treat
my daughter like a
associate i don't dr i don't hold her
accountable it's like you're my baby i'm
you're eight years old to me yeah even
though she's 21. so what what's what's
it like
um i think it's
i mean i witnessed two couples in
business and then i was the family
member in business so for me i feel like
it's harder to be like in business with
your family because
i feel like family problems can like
overpower what's really going on but at
the end of the day you have two parents
that know the same goal and what
sacrifices that need to be done for it
so even like if you have all of your
family members in business
no matter what argument's going on again
the parents they're intertwined so the
goal is bigger than whatever issue is
going on so like i've had times in the
office sorry mom um we're like maybe
we're like not talking to each other all
of our offices were separated
but
i'm not talking to my mom my sisters all
that stuff but at the end of the day my
mom and my dad were communicating
because no matter what issues were going
on at home work had to be done money had
to be brought home so i feel like in my
opinion it's harder to be in business
with family than your spouse because if
your spouse is a good spouse um you guys
have the same goal
and it doesn't matter what comes in the
way of the goal i mean comes in the way
because the goal has to get done got it
so that's
i would say
what's important is the dynamic that you
have with that family member
sure sure my brother's an adult i'm an
adult we're both men and
the way we come across each other the
way we communicate each other is as men
when he needs something done
you know i'm more reluctant on doing it
because i'm not trying to i'm not trying
to disappoint the brand myself let alone
you know i do tie that family in i'm not
trying to disappoint my brother i'm not
trying to think that
isn't it also a mindset thing because i
met your brother you guys are very
aligned same mindset yeah i'm sure
there's differences
but if you get into business with family
you might have completely different
mindset right it's like your mom
everybody's in different places one's 15
one's 18 one's married one's not like
everybody's also going through different
steps in their life
[Music]